I do mine
burp just slipped out live and direct
from Hollywood we are here at Busby
headquarters about to go on the ultimate
nacho cheese adventure we're gonna start
off at one nacho place then we're gonna
ask the people who work there if they
want to eat at their own place where
would they get nachos and so on and so
on it's on until we get to the best
nacho joint in LA and I want to have
diarrhea at the end of the day we've got
our five categories the crunch the
toppings the looks the cheese and the
drunk factor how good would these nachos
be when you've had a few too many and
we're doing this whole tour in my nacho
wagon he did not paint his truck for
this video his truck is always looking
that stupid there's no air conditioning
so just so we're heading to Buffalo Wild
Wings this is Ryan here his favorite
nacho spot it's just my favorite spot I
don't want to do you guys except
vertical ideas oh my god you don't need
a car damn let's be honest come on look
at his face you can choose that water
you may say that this looks like very
clean NACHA
we look super clean yeah this was like
the LA nachos
fire fire de queso is fresh everything
super fresh they break real easy which
we all know in nachos when your chips
break that's the biggest bummer
I'm gonna punch seven and you ten yeah
holy Sh you love these chips look at
these chunks of chicken their cues are I
can appreciate that
do they even have walk in here there's
no block or sour cream I thought they
did this is how much I remember of my
Buffalo trips yeah I'm gonna go five on
the toppings because there's no blocking
us a very huge your car shrines were
your spot junk back there
I don't want healthy ask nachos when I'm
drunk I'm going or on the plus side
though you eat healthy as nachos and
you're drunk the dads won't be that bad
tomorrow I am slightly deco stay after
drinking sheets even just seven wait
have you ever been drunk before I've
never been drunk before leaves the
speculative box again clout on no no no
no no I got a real negative real rating
put quotes around his number six on the
10 he's got 139 out of 200
that's like a scene right when I would
know because I dropped out three
colleges and I always got seed I loved
our nachos our nachos are pretty amazing
if not I would maybe say big Wayne
there's one in North Hollywood
I'm mediocre ly satisfied oh my god
we have my beer so quick I was like no
my beer
look at this seasoning on this check and
this cheese is gonna be a little firmer
a little more to deal with
that's too much crunch negative 3 given
a 7 it's like a layer of topping so I
would have liked the topping spread out
of what I like your I agree with you
yeah it's like chip blank tip you just
feel the chip on the glaybels yeah look
great I'm not panic I give that I give
that bad boy damn you're drunk you need
that floppy yes this is just you know
it's very dry you know all in all not
the worst not just but let's uh let's
get a total on this Steve final score is
Wow you guys are so intent on this 154
if you could not eat the nachos here are
big Wang's where would you go I would go
to el compadre once also
right now there's a beam at the bottom
of my beer local Collins had a little
too much of grandmas cough medicine so
our intern has to drive us now don't
crash my car okay I'm pretty confident
these notches are gonna be the best
notches we've had today because we're at
like a real Mexican joint granted nachos
aren't a traditional Mexican food but I
do think these would be the most if the
world is going on right here all right
so this is how nachos need to look I
gotta make sure it's good Jesus man what
do we say Steven this is ridiculous all
right that is it does a hot pan right
there
hi Stan walk is so fresh hmm oh right
you're on the cruise in the backyard two
days ago
I would choose this over sex any day
absolutely I still like sex but I think
these are good nauseous it's just like
it's a perfect mix of like the stretchy
and gooey we all agree is ten nine just
do that one of the old guys Steve Justin
I want to be annoyed this is why no one
likes the reason why we're all giving
this tens is not because we're drunk
because these nachos are amazing it's
also good drug factor I don't know much
about drinking
gotta get this look at 3:02 bazi of a
restaurant to like oh my god Steve be
going ham at drinks we're drinking
flaming margaritas you're gonna ruin
their score be a team player god damn it
three Oh God
yeah your final score is 189 I'm full of
nachos and margaritas and beer and crazy
don't be king too heavy on the gas hey
hey oh I'm a little gross
make your milk my mouth like butter on
toast